nach den blutigen anschlägen in sri
lanka geht die regierung von einem
islamistischen hintergrund aus
die polizei hat mehrere verdächtige
festgenommen
was bisher bekannt ist am ostersonntag
erschüttern innerhalb kurzer zeit
mächtige explosionen christliche kirchen
und luxushotels in der hauptstadt
colombo
in nico und an der ostküste des landes
in den kirchen feiern katholische
gläubige gerade die ostermesse alle
sechs anschläge werden von
selbstmordattentätern verübt stunden
später erschüttern explosionen in
vororten von colombo zwei gebäude am
abend wird in der nähe des flughafens
eine rohrbombe entdeckt und entschärft
bei den anschlägen werden fast 300
menschen getötet hunderte weitere werden
verletzt
dutzende der opfer sind ausländer aus
europa den usa china indien und japan
viele sind katholiken es sind die bisher
schwersten anschläge auch die kleine
christliche minderheit in sri lanka
die regierung macht eine einheimische
islamistengruppe für die anschläge
verantwortlich es wird geprüft ob sie
internationale unterstützung hatte die
polizei warnte kürzlich vor
anschlagsplänen der gruppe sie berief
sich auf informationen eines
ausländischen geheimdienstes untersucht
wird nun warum die warnungen folgenlos
blieben
zehn jahre nach einem blutigen
bürgerkrieg mit tamilischen rebellen ist
die sorge einer spaltung zwischen den
verschiedenen ethnien und religionen
große lankas regierung ruft die menschen
zur einheit auf die behörden haben die
sicherheitsmaßnahmen verschärft online
netzwerke wurden gesperrt es wurde eine
ausgangssperre verhängt
ein ausnahmezustand soll den
sicherheitskräften zusätzliche
befugnisse einräumen